I can't do both guys I have a list of
seven things that this 38 year old
retiree says that we need to stop
wasting money on these seven things and
if we want to retire early or retire
already at 38 35 wow that's [ __ ] my
age dude
eating out oh I know somebody that's
retired earlier than me at my age but he
looks at us and he goes I don't have the
type of memories that you guys do truly
like I know to people like that the
memories he got like another 60 years to
make memories yeah but you know what
kind of a Scrooge McDuck he is oh yeah
and his wife was 31 at the time that she
retired Wow the bucket list are you
ready food credit cards clothes I know
there's a lot of things like number one
it is eating out yeah there was this
2019 survey of more than 2000 Americans
69 percent said that they wasted money
dining out and that also includes
takeouts
buying lunch or eating drink oh yeah I
mean eating drinks orders tree eating
drinks always kills you check us out
though that's not a waste to me cuz it's
mental relaxation sometimes not
technically like a waste cuz yeah you're
enjoying whatever you're spending on but
the whole point here is that this is
like if you couldn't if we feel
personally attacked by this [ __ ]
- and we need to fight back he doesn't
know me he doesn't know my struggle you
don't know what I'm doing know that I
never need to retire because I love my
life yeah it's hard I don't want to cook
anything yeah I'm with you on that you
don't know that I like to get a nice
medium-rare Wagyu steak every once in a
while a fine and $3,000 on champagne I
don't even remember I like this guy's
theories I want to retire sooner so you
don't even hurt if the champagne was
good
okay so I can't be retiring early is a
nice feeling though I bet there was this
2019 report from ladder which is a life
insurance company I found that the
average adult spends one thousand four
hundred and ninety seven dollars per
month on non essentials which is about
eighteen thousand a year it's really
non-essential things that were talking
about you about to tell you right now
those weights of them are essential it's
essential as long as possible in this
show they're [ __ ] Assange in well
video not this not this video though so
never mind I'll give a full watching
architect because we have an off the
record that's that's sponsored by Posey
yeah exactly so usually it's about seven
hundred fifty dollars per month on
eating out oh yeah yeah yeah that's
pretty crazy
that's a lot of money that's like to
dinner as a brown Mads you're a baller
do you know if you if you go to like no
so they're saying restaurant meals is
two hundred and ten dollars a month
oh dear thanks to the hundred and eighty
nine dollars old a delivery is a hundred
and seventy eight and buying lunches 173
which adds up to about nine thousand
dollars a year this person doesn't like
to live yeah he doesn't have the
memories we have yeah yeah what are they
eating [ __ ] broccoli and [ __ ] chicken
breast they're all jacked
honestly this guy's probably healthier
too we have like no [ __ ] body
percentage okay the next thing we can
judge it is phone upgrades whatever my
phone is my work how about that boo I'm
not like this guy over here wait which
one's that oh look at like yeah what's
the owner go ahead 10/10 but you don't
have the 11 that's great because I'm
saving my money yeah you're so thrifty
got the 10 with the wide angle Oh
actually because of you I can't see and
I want to get the news ha ha ha
me too actually you sold us on it looks
like
my email you want Amina we want to
retire early but yeah they're saying
that depending on your carrier buying a
new model can cost you an extra $25 a
month or $600 more to buy it outright
that's true for them like for this
couple here they have saved up to 1500
every year that they've decided not to
what do they have the iPhone ones though
but if you're on a fixed income that's a
lot because you want to save as much as
you can and add that up and then put it
into something that's gonna give you
money back for what it's like investing
in [ __ ] is the biggest thing you can do
for yourself so that's how they were
able to retire early especially for his
wife so she ended up putting in her
entire salary straight into their
investment portfolio and that's how they
were able to see because I'm a slave to
my passion mmm I'm just jealous I get it
I'm asleep in my face I am a slave to my
passion I have to work there is no
quitting yeah that's what I do but
you're happy because you work but then
I'm sad because I have to work mm-hmm
it's a catch-22 is a cash but I want to
ask these people hey what did retiring
early did do to you yeah are you bored
my business partners they retired early
and they're like it's not what it seems
they're not fulfilled they're like we
needed to do something because after
three years of just vacationing it was
getting sad I Bitcoin because I work and
I work because a Bitcoin story of my
life bro bitcoins doing bare right now
that's do it okay
yeah yeah well one guy didn't know the
guy next to you just said it was doing
bad he bought him wave ahead of the menu
he's still up same dude it's okay but I
but that's what I'm saying I work
because a Bitcoin right now but pretty
soon I think we're all gonna be around
yeah we're all gonna be rich rich
[ __ ] rich ass [ __ ] I don't think I
will be rich cuz I'm addicted to
investing in risky things that probably
won't bring back any money and I just
keep pumping money into it what like
horse racing and [ __ ] gambling gambling
well that's the same gambling
horse-racing same thing right no because
if I can't go to Vegas and I'm gonna be
gambling Matthew my friends dreams
gotta live in Vegas so I can gamble it
all you're not you're so attached to us
you're not leaving no we moved the whole
operation Vegas oh nice trying to
convince us to go there yeah what are
you thinking about if the whole state
can be a humidifier and I'm down you
could bring a humidifier to promise baby
you can't hang with it so I'm [ __ ]
her we could probably install a
humidifier with I'll cheat the homes are
that's true like the top of the line
yeah but what about when you go out
though you ready we're just gonna all
connect our houses together so there's
just like tunnels we put a bubble over
our entire community bio dome it's so
second we can have our own religion dojo
I like to minify the religion okay
okay moving on you mean isn't number
three on this list is clothing and
apparel the average American spends
about 1866 dollars a year on clothing
and apparel I don't
joke's on you during again I get
sponsored by barbell Berget yeah goody
brand.com
goody grand a thousand dollars a bottle
good or goody bread or getting back or
barbourville games if you're gonna spend
please spend it on us because we spent a
lot of money on Bitcoin hey Steve merch
coming soon man merch coming very soon
Steve can I be in charge of your merch
we all Steve all merch all the time yeah
I spend money on clothes that I don't
even wear and I always end you so much'
clothes you know why cuz you it helps
you write what no like I get free [ __ ]
and then there's things I see that I
feel like oh these are really cool I'd
like to wear this and then I always just
kind of end up wearing the same [ __ ]
black t-shirt and you're tearing up my
heart when I'm with you to see what
nobody will do business with me if I
don't look pristine
you do it Christine Oh what are you
gonna say you never look
I was waiting for that for what verbal
abuse yeah it feels not the same what's
going on Jill what's happening you want
it too bad a little too thirsty Joe you
said you gamble I do you lottery ticket
no I control my gambling scratchy
scratchers yeah because that's number
four lottery - Kampai some people spend
[ __ ] hundreds a month Wow 8600 that's
almost 100 days almost 100 I'm not that
stupid I just buy penny stocks you take
it's a date you know what's even crazier
what's back here is that 59% of
Millennials which is us believe winning
the lottery is a reasonable way to
retire what though yeah it's not it's
not a reasonable way to retire if you
just randomly have like 40 million
dollars it's not a reasonable way sounds
reasonable to me no it's people blow
through their fortunes because they're
not financially smart when they get that
give that money to me and see what
happens what happened well you almost
always give half there fortunately their
friends and family and then they buy a
huge goddamn house and then they buy a
sick car and then they're [ __ ] out
they're having so much fun well in taxes
take half of it right off the bad - they
don't count that in either that's true
so they're saying here in this article
that this addictive this addictive
habits could save you about 1032 dollars
a year
okay which one the lottery ticket yes
next one is extended warranties extended
warranties have become a big business
roughly 40 billion dollars Wow and so
they're saying if you just skip out on
this extended warranty like paying for
it you will save yourself a ton of it
that's true because I was like I ain't
gonna buy the insurance for the refunds
for the plane tickets and then I
actually didn't want to take the plane
anymore I was like [ __ ] I should have
got the refund but even if you do that
at least in my experience when I have
gotten the the extra insurance to cancel
it still doesn't it's not valid because
I didn't read the [ __ ] fine print and
they're like it's only valid if there's
like a crazy emergency where someone
dies or you're
my good health I need everything you
have to be hospitalized they wouldn't
return it that's [ __ ] you sure for
the plane tickets is so stupid yeah cuz
even when you do it and like let's say
you wanna like be like hey I the
insurance on this [ __ ] it's such a
[ __ ] process to get your money back
like it's so dumb
we had a doctor's no we couldn't get the
money but like can you like get like a
like a like a reschedule though how
about that no sometimes you can pay like
an extra 200 bucks or something and then
do it oh I am gonna [ __ ] call my
lawyer one of the best things one of the
smartest decisions I ever made was
getting a bumper to bumper warranty on
my Mini Cooper when I first got it
before like in it lasted for like the
first five years or 50,000 miles and
I've barely [ __ ] drove that thing so
it was sick because I had all kinds of
problems I ended up having like six
grand worth of problems that I easily
paid for because of the warranty so you
never that's a good win huh how much was
extended warranty it was it was about
$50 a month hmm and then I had a five
year lease so six hundreds yeah it
wasn't much oh that reminds me I need
help to talk my tire iron
I need my tire pompton I'm gonna I need
my left tires
Ryan pump his tire my tire you gotta get
a pump right now guys listen this is
important [ __ ] you can't forget this
comes I have a nail my [ __ ] back tire
that's important no I know you stopped
the shooting no we got to do it well let
me just quickly tell you yeah you please
sits other two with cable TV and impulse
purchases they're saying that for this
couple they chose YouTube TV because it
includes more top channels for the base
price of any competitor eight of money
and you should be wary of spending on
too many streaming services because yeah
I do that
maybe watching all of them the real
question knows how much money they make
the year how much did they save and how
much time I don't end it at the suck
dick for side hustle he probably has a
other blog post about it I don't know
but I just know that in 2016 he quit his
six bigger job in software development
and retired at age 35 that's all I know
there's a movement called afire freedom
in retiring early okay fire I I
cancelled my spectrum cable and I kept
the Internet and I only watch cable
through Hulu because Hulu has a live
view I can't my mom's old so she needs
the old-school [ __ ] she needs a remote
that's like this that you hit guide and
then there's that thing right but
anything else bucks remote so big that
you lose your couch before you lose the
remote or people could just go on Jomon
academy.com and i show people how to
like budget for free and it's like basic
finance and budgeting and you can you
know the world should learn about this
[ __ ] or else aw they're gonna get into
big trouble
yeah huh we're free
[Music]